[Música]
hola este es un nuevo episodio de medio
ambiente los saluda maría clara calle un
tratado para proteger las aguas marinas
que no le pertenecen a nadie y que aún
así ocupan la mitad de la superficie del
planeta eso es lo que intentan los
gobiernos del mundo en la reunión que se
realiza en las oficinas de la onu en
nueva york entre el 15 y el 26 de agosto
si lo logran sería el primer acuerdo
para proteger la biodiversidad de las
aguas internacionales pero el reto no es
nada fácil de lograr de hecho se
esperaba que la conferencia de los
océanos que se realizó apenas en junio
en portugal diera pasos importantes para
lograr el tratado sobre las aguas de
alta mar y esto no ocurrió a pesar de
que naciones unidas sí reconoció una
emergencia oceánica
from space cuando vemos la tierra desde
el espacio realmente valoramos que
vivimos en un planeta azul el océano nos
conecta a todos
seattle y desgraciadamente damos por
sentada la existencia del océano y hoy
nos enfrentamos a lo que yo llamaría una
emergencia oceánica en si wii más
tenemos que cambiar la marea ante la
falta de compromisos contundentes en
lisboa los activistas le han apostado a
la conferencia intergubernamental de
nueva york
hemos escuchado un montón de compromisos
voluntarios muchas promesas muchas
buenas palabras y por lo que ha pasado
en otros años sabemos que si las
palabras salvarán a los océanos estos no
estarían al borde del colapso así que en
agosto cuando los gobiernos se reúnen en
la onu realmente necesitan pactar un
tratado oceánico contundente y richie y
esta es la última sesión que se tiene
programada desde hace una década
comenzaron las discusiones sobre un
tratado que obliga a los estados a
proteger la alta mar y así detener la
pérdida de biodiversidad marina en el
que es el ecosistema más grande del
mundo pero que son las aguas de alta mar
para entenderlo digamos que son comunes
las comparación con el viejo oeste pues
es una zona en la que no existe casi
ninguna ley internacional y no le
pertenece a ningún estado por ejemplo
allí es donde ocurre en gran parte de
las pescas masivas ilegales técnicamente
la alta mar son las aguas que están más
allá de las 200 millas náuticas contadas
a partir de la costa ya pesar de que
esto constituye dos terceras partes del
océano menos del 1% está protegida en
comparación con el 12 por ciento de las
superficies terrestres que se cuentan
con alguna protección
ya ha habido algunos intentos para
revertir la situación en 2021 más de 50
países se comprometieron a proteger el
30 por ciento de las tierras y de los
océanos del mundo antes del año 2030
pero una pregunta que se hacen
constantemente los científicos es que
30% se debe proteger en altamar a esto
un estudio publicado en marín policy y
realizado por 13 universidades señaló al
menos 10 lugares clave entre ellos se
cuentan por ejemplo los dorsales de
salas y gómez y también el de nazca
además el domo térmico de costa rica o
los montes submarinos de corner rice o
la meseta de las mascareñas entre otros
que ustedes ven en sus pantallas lo que
tienen en común estos sitios es que
tienen una extraordinaria biodiversidad
y que son fundamentales para la
conservación de las especies del mundo
otra razón importante para proteger las
aguas de alta mar es que el océano en
general juega un papel fundamental para
combatir la crisis climática y es que
los organismos absorben el carbono y
además éste se entierra en el lecho
marino así las aguas han absorbido el 30
por ciento del dióxido de carbono de
todo el planeta por eso si las aguas
internacionales no se protege no sólo
están en riesgo los peces y la cadena de
alimentos que obtenemos de allí sino que
su afectación también impactaría los
patrones del clima a su vez la crisis
climática también golpea a los océanos
que se han vuelto un 26 por ciento más
ácidos desde la era preindustrial según
la alianza hay 6 por eso los activistas
protestaron en nueva york' para
presionar a la onu y a los gobiernos a
que finalmente logren un acuerdo
vinculante
hemos eliminado cerca del 90% de los
peces grandes del mundo y aún así hay
pesca en alta mar casi sin regulación el
cambio climático está teniendo un
impacto enorme en nuestros océanos pero
los océanos también pueden ser parte de
la solución obviamente debemos dejar de
quemar combustibles fósiles pero los
océanos saludables también ayudan a
enfrentar la crisis climática en sur
esta es la quinta sesión que ha hecho la
onu desde 2018 para intentar lograr un
tratado sobre aguas internacionales y
hasta ahora no han logrado un consenso
las discusiones en nueva york' se
centrarán básicamente en cuatro grandes
puntos que son en donde radican las
mayores diferencias el primero son los
recursos marinos si bien hay un consenso
en que ningún estado tiene la soberanía
sobre estos recursos la pelea es para
definir si un gobierno o una empresa o
una persona pueden o no apropiarse de
ellos y cómo se reparten los beneficios
que de allí se obtengan otro tema
difícil es cuántas áreas se debe
proteger además de cómo medir el impacto
ambiental en alta mar y quien se encarga
de vigilarlo finalmente también hablarán
de las capacidades tecnológicas para
investigar la biodiversidad en estas
aguas que hasta ahora ha logrado
entender la ciencia menos de un 0,1 por
ciento
es por eso que la conferencia en nueva
york' sobre las aguas de alta mar es
fundamental para garantizar no sólo la
vida marina sino también para proteger
una de las mejores herramientas que
tiene la humanidad contra la crisis
climática los océanos con esta
expectativa nos despedimos consulta en
este y todos los programas de
medioambiente en france 24 punto com nos
vemos